how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the loki series
was absolutely fantastic not only did we
get to see
our loki back in action but we kind of
got a new loki getting to see a new side
of him
and then we were introduced to a lady
loki sylvie
and she was absolutely fantastic as well
of course the series introduced the tva
which exists
outside of time which can be kind of
confusing for a lot of people
which i totally understand and a big
question that everybody had about the
loki series is
when exactly does this take place where
in the marvel cinematic universe's
timeline does
the loki series fall in comparison to
one division the falcon and the winter
soldier avengers end game etc
after all the tva is responsible for
going and arresting people who create
brands timelines and nexus events
so a big question that a lot of people
actually have is
why didn't the tva interfere with wanda
why didn't they interfere with the
avengers going back in time clearly they
must have created some branch timelines
right
well now we have an explanation for both
of these as marvel and disney have come
out and officially revealed
where in the marvel cinematic universe's
timeline loki takes place
and it may not actually be when you
think it is it's definitely not where i
thought it was
but don't worry we'll dive into it and
talk about what exactly this means
moving forward and of course if you want
to stay up to date on all things
relating to the mcu be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
so if you go to disney plus website
right now and you click
on the marvel icon it'll give you a
bunch of different sections
there's a featured section that just
shows most of their new stuff there's an
animated section there is a marvel
legacy section that shows the movies
like
the x-men and the fantastic four then
you have things like marvel phase one
marvel phase two and marvel phase three
and four and then you get to the section
that says
marvel cinematic universe in timeline
order
meaning the order that all of these
movies take place
in the timeline of the mcu not in real
life
but in the mcu for example the first
movie is captain america the first
avenger which takes place in 1942
the next movie is captain marvel which
takes place in 1995.
then we make a huge jump to iron man
which takes place in 2008 so it's the
timeline order
inside of the marvel cinematic universe
not the dates which they came out in
real life
because obviously we know that iron man
was the first one to come out
so right now as stated by marvel and
disney the marvel cinematic
universe timeline order is captain
america the first avenger
captain marvel iron man iron man 2
thor the avengers thor the dark world
iron man 3
captain america the winter soldier the
guardians of the galaxy
the guardians of the galaxy vol 2
avengers age of ultron
ant-man captain america civil war black
widow
black panther doctor strange thor
ragnarok
ant-man and the wasp avengers infinity
war avengers in-game and then
loki loki actually comes right after
avengers in game and before one division
it goes
avengers in game loki one division and
then the falcon and the winter soldier
so disney and marvel say that one
division comes before the falcon and the
winter soldier but after loki and this
could
actually explain a lot including how
wanda possibly heard her kids
in the post credit scene and i have a
big theory about that which i'm about to
talk about but first let's talk about
the avengers going back in time and how
the tva never stepped in for them
now this was kind of explained during
the loki series but i know some people
didn't really get it so i'll go ahead
and explain further especially since we
saw the very last episode of loki now
the first thing that you have to realize
is that he who remains the person in
charge of the tva and in charge of
everything that happens essentially
had a plan a very specific plan and
everything that he did
and everything that he had the tva do
were all
in line with that plan and his plan was
simply to get
loki from avengers in game who escaped
with the tesseract in 2012
and his female variant sylvie the plan
was to get them
to the citadel get them to him we
learned that he wanted them to take his
spot he wanted the two of them to run
the tva together
erasing timelines like he did and like
he set the tva up to do
this is truthfully why the tva grabbed
loki in 2012 when he escaped with the
tesseract because
he who remains wanted him he explained
in the loki finale that
every single thing that happened to loki
and sylvie was simply
he who remains setting everything up to
bring them to him
so loki was supposed to take the
tesseract and escape because
loki was supposed to fall into the hands
of the tva and eventually make his way
to he who remains
the avengers were supposed to do what
they did because that all
led to loki being captured by the tva
also since captain america went back in
time and put the infinity stones back it
seemingly didn't really create any
huge nexus event branch timelines and if
it did i'm assuming the tva actually
took care of that
and we just didn't see it on screen the
tva did let some things fly like captain
america going back in time and having a
full life with peggy carter but then
again there is the theory that that
actually didn't create a brand's
timeline and that captain america was
simply in
the main mcu timeline the entire time
and when captain america visits peggy
and she's looking at her kids they're
actually
steve's kids now the writers and the
directors seem to have a disagreement
about this but the writers did say that
the whole entire time they did believe
that steve was peggy's husband and the
father of her kids
and if that is the case that would be
why no branch timeline was ever created
from steve going back in time and
staying with peggy he was actually
always supposed to do that
so really what happened in 2012 with
loki escaping was supposed to happen
because he was supposed to make his way
to he who remains
and like he who remains said he paved
the path for them to get to him
now ultimately when they did get to him
he gave them two choices
take over the tva or kill him and his
evil
variants would come millions of them
infinite amounts of them would come
arloki wanted to think about it but
sylvie who had been fighting her entire
life to get to where she was so that she
could kill whoever was in charge of the
tva
didn't really care she just wanted her
revenge and she took it she killed
he who remains and then kang came loki
makes his way back to the tva and there
is a huge statue of
kang the conqueror and this has pretty
big implications on the future of the
mcu including
one division spider-man no way home and
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
now killing he who remains sent the
multiverse back into play there was just
one sacred timeline now there is a
gigantic multiverse and it definitely is
in madness and this could definitely
explain why we never saw doctor strange
in one division
he clearly had a lot to deal with since
loki took place before one division more
than likely doctor strange was trying to
get a grasp on this
multiverse of madness concept however
wanda might actually be the key to
everything because it looks like she is
a nexus being
in marvel comics nexus beans are
keystones of the multiverse and they're
pretty crucial to
its coherence and stability and since
our multiverse looks like it could use
some stability it looks like wanda is
going to be the key
however doctor strange may find it
problematic to try and recruit wanda
as wanda in the post-credits scene heard
her kids
now wanda created her kids out of magic
they
aren't technically real when wanda
released the town from her magic the
kids went away and disappeared so how
exactly did she hear them
in the post-credits scene of one
division well now that we know that loki
took place before one division this
actually makes sense
there is more than likely a branch
timeline where her kids are
actually real and these are the kids
that she is hearing she is searching the
multiverse to try and find a reality
where her children are real so she can
go and take them back
so this seemingly answers that big
question because that was a huge
cliffhanger for us
if her children aren't real how did she
hear them well again since it's the
multiverse of madness and we saw just a
ton
of branch timelines created there's
probably one at least where her kids are
indeed real
and now that she's got the dark cold she
is definitely going to be going after
them
which is something that we probably will
see take place in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness because since
wanda again
is a nexus bean doctor strange is
definitely going to want her help and
that's probably why we're going to be
seeing her again
in multiverse of madness it actually
helps a lot that marvel and disney came
out and
listed the marvel cinematic universe
timeline order for us
and now that we know that loki takes
place before one division and the falcon
and the winter soldier
a few things that we had questions about
seem to make a lot more sense now
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below
does this timeline order make sense to
you or do you think
differently don't forget to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof